how about we ask you about suffering and
when I will you talk a lot about
needless suffering and you could have
easily had a whole life of needless
suffering after what happened yeah
in the utopia is suffering necessary not
at all okay so what would how do we get
to we've talked about how we do the 1
billion happy if that can become 2
billion happy we can have artificial
general intelligence that it looks at
civilization and learns and there we go
we were good we treat each other well
then if we get to this point of utopia
lots of people talk about suffering
being so valuable to learn from absolute
crap let's see yeah unpack absolute crap
I need to go back I promise I'll come
back to the difference between pain and
suffering if I if I don't please ask me
but I need you to understand what
suffering is right so I I struggled with
the idea I was very happy at age 23 I
became very unhappy at age 29 at age 29
I was a director at they trade that I
was meeting making a ton of money I was
so wealthy so blessed in every way and I
was clinically depressed I was miserable
and I started to say to myself as an
engineer let's define happiness let's
define what that thing is that I'm
searching for so that at least I can
find it right and I did it in the most
unusual way I I took as many data points
as I could of moments in my life where I
felt happy I plotted them on charts
trying to find the trendline between
them that trend line that approximates
all of the points in my life I felt
happy is the happiness equation now
there is one common thing across every
moment in your life you've ever felt
happy right one common thing across all
of the moments in your life you felt
unhappy it has nothing to do with the
absolute event of your life so really
interestingly every moment in your life
where you've ever felt happy was a
moment where life was seemed to be going
your way as simple as that
right you sit in this room your brain
immediately compares the event to its
expectations of what is a safe
model for your survival it starts to
think okay this room is a little too
cold we're going to be here for two
hours is this okay right that hmm
truly is what unhappiness is so believe
it or not happiness there is an equation
happiness is equal to or greater than
the difference between the events of
your life and your expectation of how
life should behave every single event
that crosses your path your brain solves
to see if it meets its expectations or
misses its expectations right and that
gives you a few very interesting
definitions of what happiness is one is
happiness is not fun it's different
going up you know jumping up and down
and dancing in a party that's not
happiness happiness is that peaceful
feeling you get when you're okay with
life as it is equanimity yeah it's
basically I look at I mean you all have
friends and partners and people in your
life right you can look at your partner
and I can guarantee or find a good or
find a few things that are amazing and a
few things that perhaps you would have
liked to change right if you look at the
things that you would like to change
you're gonna be unhappy in that
relationship yeah right if you look at
them in totality and say look as they
are I'm okay I don't want to be any
other place when you find that moment
you found happiness rain for example
doesn't make you happy or unhappy rain
has no intrinsic intrinsic value of
happiness if you're a farmer and you
want to plant you know water your plants
rain makes you happy right if you're you
know we're going through a drought and
we wanna make sure we stop the fires
rain makes us unhappy it makes us happy
if you want a suntan and it rains you
feel unhappy rain has no value of
happiness it's just the comparison
between rain and what you want life to
be these are expectations and indeed so
it's events - expectations events -
expectations
now that throws a very interesting
definition of unhappiness unhappiness in
that case is just a survival mechanism
it's a survival mechanism it's your
brain looking at the world around it if
it finds that the
world matches its expectations it does
something amazing it shuts the [ __ ] up
right when it shuts up your default
setting as a child is happy right the
problem is if your brain realizes that
this does not match my expectations it
alerts you what does it alert you in in
the form of it alerts you in the form of
emotional pain emotional pain is I'm
worried about the exam tomorrow that
worry is what triggers me to get up and
study I regret that I said something
rude to my friend that regret makes me
call and make amends right now emotional
pain is useful unhappiness isn't